hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology I'm back after a gap the
Gap was associated with our annual
summer school our 21st summer school and
our High School summer research program
very interesting for me
I think we had uh
six to six students at our summer school
grown-ups
and 61 at our high school program so I
got to try and come up with
whatever it is 130 or so projects and
got to meet all kinds of interesting
people
and learn about all sorts of things but
uh now we're back and uh we'll be
continuing with these live streams with
a few gaps over the course of the summer
here
all right let's see
looking at some questions here let's see
Judy asks can you discuss a bit of your
personal history with AI when did you
first become interested in the idea
that is an interesting question actually
when I was a kid so I I grew up in kind
of the 1960s and 1970s uh
and uh
I certainly would look at books about
the future so to speak
um this must have been times like
um uh
196678 I was six seven eight years old
uh there were all these books about the
future and they had various kinds of
things in them I might say by the way
that that uh in addition to books about
the future there was also a little bit
of Television about the future so for
instance uh there was Doctor Who which I
think is still running but it was it was
a thing back then and there were visions
of AI that already existed in those
television programs back at that time so
there were the the Daleks who were I
think their their backstory later
developed differently but they were
these kinds of uh uh sort of somewhat
conical round-headed shaped uh robotic
things that would wander around with a
with a single kind of um tentacle
hanging out so to speak at the front uh
that were mostly rather
um rather nasty creatures
um but they were kind of a a version of
sort of roboticism and Ai and so on and
then there was a I think there were
things called the Cybermen uh who were
kind of uh playing off the the
cybernetics
uh kind of theme also in Doctor Who uh
who had some more complicated sort of
human-like form and story which I now
forget
but so you know one part of sort of the
the ambient vision of AI was these kind
of mostly
malevolent kind of robotic Critters
then I remember 1968 when the movie 2001
A Space Odyssey came out uh seeing that
that had a sort of a version of an AI in
the form of the Hal computer in that
movie and that was another kind of uh
introduction to this sort of ambient
view of kind of AI as uh kind of a a
perhaps in in many cases malevolent kind
of influence on things
I I guess around that time also the Star
Trek television series came out I do
remember that okay silly personal story
uh the um there was a sort of prime time
of American Kids television was like 6
p.m on Saturdays or something and there
were a series of different programs that
existed at that time and there was you
know you would look them up in this
actual physical
uh uh publication called radio times I
think the US version is TV Guide
um that was a printed list of what
programs would appear at what time and
uh there had been a series of really in
my opinion quite unwatchable kinds of uh
television programs that have been in
that particular slot on Saturdays and so
on and so then there appeared this this
new thing that was listed as Star Trek
and for the first many months I assumed
that this was another one of these to me
unwatchable programs that had something
to do with horse tracking and it was
some kind of uh you know celebrity horse
tracking kind of thing and I completely
ignored it and I don't know how I came
to actually uh watch Star Trek uh for
the first time but um uh and I found it
um sort of charmingly American I was
growing up in England
um in fact several years later I had
occasion to write one of these kind of
essays about for some I don't know
English literature thing and I I um
ended up writing
about two pieces of American television
one was Star Trek and the other was a a
police drama called Kojak and I had
noticed my my big Discovery was that um
there were both of these had sort of uh
various allusions to the American
conditions so to speak with them uh the
I think my giveaway was some episode of
of Kojak where at the end of the the
episode there's some disastrous happen
and some building is burning in the
background and this uh you know
detective character turns the camera and
says I think something like the mass of
men lead lives of quiet desperation
which didn't seem like it really fitted
in with the usual way this character
talked so it was kind of a giveaway that
that had to be some kind of literary
illusion so to speak so I went and
looked it up and found out it was I know
it's due to a row Emerson I'm not sure
one of those kinds of characters who uh
used to
live 100 years earlier in the area that
I live around Concord Massachusetts but
in any case the uh that was sort of a
giveaway and then then I kind of
realized that in Star Trek there were
lots of sort of American Frontiers kinds
of metaphors and so on but in any case
Star Trek featured a an AI computer and
that again was part of the sort of
ambient experience of kind of what AI
would be like seen from the late 1960s
and then and then there were books about
the future I do remember one that had
this notion of teaching machines which
was some kind of AI based thing which
would be the future of education and
there was kind of an illustration of uh
uh some kind of sort of screen-based um
uh computer thing
any case I I didn't actually you know
computers were not something that one
saw in real life back in those days and
so sort of the only image of what
computers were like was the occasional
kind of uh uh thing in a in a television
program or something and uh or or in
something or in a vision of a future
like 2001
um and uh when they did appear and I'm
not sure when they first started showing
up but when computers did start showing
up and kind of as background props in
television shows and so on they it would
usually be the the twitching uh nine
track tapes that would be the most
visible so in those days uh one was
dealing with mainframe computers like
the IBM 360
and the way that data tended to be
stored some of it was stored on on
rotating disks
um that was sort of fixed for the
computer but quite often data was stored
on magnetic tape and so it was a really
common thing to see uh data being sort
of found it was like kind of databases
being stored out on tape and the tapes
would be twitching around uh trying to
uh seek the the appropriate pieces of
data so that was the kind of most common
image of a computer
uh I think I first saw a computer in
1970 when I was like 10 years old and it
was kind of a Mainframe computer from a
distance so to speak and it didn't seem
at all like anything ai-ish in those
days I first used a computer in 1972 a
big kind of desk sized computer that
again didn't really seem very ai-ish and
I used it to do computations eventually
uh well various kinds of attempted
physics simulations and so on but it was
a computer program with paper tape and
things like this and rather far away
from the kind of how like version of a
computer in 2001.
so
I guess that I didn't really pay much
attention in the 1970s there were there
wasn't a lot
that I remember of kind of the the sort
of AI wasn't for me at least a big thing
in those days uh there were things where
people would talk about uh it was still
the case
well in the night in the 1960s it had
still been the case that sort of
spacecraft and space were kind of a big
Frontier of technology and I do remember
that I was very taken with the um with a
computer that was supposed to be on a
deep space probe maybe going to the
outer planets uh that was a self-testing
and repairing computer and I was
certainly very curious this must have
been when I was I don't know eight nine
years old I was very curious how such a
self-testing and repairing computer
could possibly work and I kind of
wondered you know what did that really
mean and and how did it how was it in a
position to kind of uh test and repair
itself so to speak I think in actuality
it was something where it had kind of
three-way redundancy and things would
kind of vote on the outcome and so on
and maybe it had some capability to to
get new code that it could load for
itself
but anyway I think then my own kind of
next exposure to these kinds of things
was
uh well I I started using computers to
do kind of mathematical computation
starting uh in Earnest around 1976
and uh I didn't think of that as being
anything particularly ai-ish it was just
okay I can get a computer to do Algebra
I can get a computer to do calculus uh I
think that people had uh there was some
part of the the work that had been done
along those lines particularly coming
out of MIT that had been very much
themed on the this is going to be part
of the story of artificial intelligence
but to me this was mostly just a
practical thing about making a computer
do the math I didn't want to do by hand
myself
but that whole set of things caused me
in 1979 to start building my first own
big computer system SMP symbolic
manipulation program kind of Forerunner
of Mathematica and woven language and in
the development of SMP a lot of what I
thought about was kind of what should
the foundation for computation really be
like I was kind of looking back at the
last sort of many years of mathematical
logic that have been done in Lambda
calculus and combinators and things like
this again I don't think I really
thought of that as being a thing that
was anything like artificial
intelligence I thought of that as being
a thing that was like kind of
computation and the entrainment of
things like mathematics and logic into
computation
but then
the place where I did start thinking
about this was probably 1980 I
started wondering okay I can represent I
can do all the sort of sophisticated
mathematical type computation within
this SMP system I knew it was much more
General than just being for mathematics
I had built it to be sort of a
representation of arbitrary computations
and so then I started wondering well
what about kind of the rest of what
brains do and the rest of what we do in
thinking and so on and one of the things
about SMP was like wolfen language today
it was very much based on the idea of
having symbolic Expressions that can
represent anything and then defining
Transformations for symbolic Expressions
saying if you have an Express symbolic
expression that looks like this it
should get transformed into one that
looks like that
and so I very quickly realized that sort
of my idealization of thinking was
rather than just saying there is a
specific symbolic expression or a
symbolic expression which just has kind
of blanks in it where you can stuff any
sub-expression in there get transformed
into this that really something more
like human thinking was something where
there was kind of a fuzzy pattern that
had to be matched uh I didn't really
think so much about images in those days
although maybe I did a little bit but
kind of like anything that's an image of
a cat even though the pixels may be very
differently configured should be
something that will be transformed into
a picture of a dog or whatever it is or
into into the the uh string cat or
something that that the sort of essence
I imagined of kind of the process of
thinking was something not so unlike
this kind of transformation of symbolic
Expressions that I defined as the core
of SMP but it was something where
instead of having this kind of
well-defined symbolic representation of
the expression be the thing that was
transformed that it said should be some
much fuzzier kind of thing where I could
kind of deal with kind of these these
very different sorts of things but very
different kinds of presentations of
things like the cat still thinking of it
as the concept of a cat and at that time
I remember being interested in the
notion of kind of fuzzy hashing so you
know when you make a hash code a hash
code is something where you'll take
something like a word and you kind of
grind It Up by some algorithm and turn
it into for example a number and that's
very useful because if you take a word
and you map every word into a number
between you know one and fifty thousand
or something or maybe one in a hundred
you can say well do I yet have this word
if I have nothing that hashed to 82 or
something and this word hashes to 82
then I know I don't have that word yet
those kinds of things but ordinary
hashing has the feature that yes two
very different things can hash to the
same number but it doesn't have the
feature that two nearby things like two
different images of a cat will will hash
to the same thing and so I got
interested in the question of could I
invent some way of doing sort of fuzzy
hashing that would let one kind of uh
deal with things in a way that seemed
more like human thinking worked and that
was around 1980 and I kind of imagined
that maybe I could do that and include
it as part of the SMP system as part of
something which would be sort of an
alternative to the traditional pattern
matching of SMP and and kind of in
pattern matching an SMP really much like
wolfen language you take an expression
and you say it's like f of x blank and
that x-blank can stand for any other
expression you can put that in there
it's going to be named X and then you
can do whatever you want on the kind of
right hand side of that rule
well in SMP it wasn't x blank or X
underscore as it is important language
it was dollar X and I had a bunch of
less good ideas about what the right
hand side of that transformation looked
like and so on but one of the things
that I did try to do in SMP was make a
sort of more elaborate way of handling
pattern matching so for example if I had
something like f of dollar X comma
dollar y comma dollar X Plus dollar y
so uh in in Wilson language
uh that those x's and y's
would just match if you could stuff
another expression in place of the X and
Y so if you had a and b you'd have a and
b there and then the dollar X Plus
dollar y would be a plus b and all is
good but in SMP I was kind of obsessed
with the the question of what will
happen if you said f of
one comma one comma two
and would that match because the two
isn't literally dollar X Plus dollar y
but it is something that in some
semantic sense is dollar X Plus dollar y
if dollar X is one and dollar Y is one
and so I had this very elaborate uh kind
of implementation of so what I called
semantic pattern matching which was a
way of doing evaluation inside the
pattern matching process it was a very
bad idea that may be be clear about that
point it caused the pattern matcher to
have all kinds of strange slowdowns and
kind of undecidable situations it could
get into it was it was not something
that was a good match with the process
of pattern matching with this kind of
symbolic transformation idea but in any
case it was something which kind of went
a little bit in the direction of sort of
the fuzzy pattern matching idea that I
had thought was kind of the notion of
what was needed for a kind of a a more
brain like thinking like kind of thing
so in any case I I thought about that a
bunch at that time I had all kinds of I
just found recently actually some notes
I made at that time with all kinds of
ideas about the way in which one would
uh kind of set such a system up and and
how it would be a little bit about how
it would learn but I wasn't so concerned
about how it would learn I was most more
concerned about how it would sort of do
the um uh do uh kind of um
uh do the matching process
okay so then I guess the next thing that
happened probably
um this must have been 19
uh well let's see it must have been 1981
a strange thing that happened was this
at the time there started to be
enthusiasm for so-called expert systems
expert systems had the idea that one
would take kind of knowledge that humans
had and somehow encoded in computable
form something that I'd been much
interested in in later years but at the
time it was kind of this process where
you would kind of interview a human and
you would sort of write up code that
represented what the human uh kind of
the the humans kind of uh map of
knowledge and so on and way of thinking
about things and sort of magically put
that on a computer
and I was never deeply involved in doing
that and I don't think I ever really
whenever I looked at systems that were
supposed to be doing that it was like
well it's just a piece of code it didn't
that I wasn't sort of I didn't think
there was anything terribly magic about
them but
the first company I started that was a
company to commercialize SMP it's a
company called computer mathematics
Corporation and in those days one of my
many mistakes was that I was at that
point out of a 20 year old or so uh sort
of young academic and I thought well I
don't really know how to run companies I
should bring in other people to do that
and the folks I brought in were people
who had gotten very interested in this
kind of expert systems idea and had gone
off and started another they also had
another company they were trying to get
started that was really in the space of
expert systems kinds of things
and so in the end uh through a series of
of kind of twists and turns the computer
mathematics Corporation merged with the
company that was created by some
overlapping set of the same people uh
that and the merged company became
called inference Corporation and uh
which is kind of a very modern sounding
term I suppose in these days I I kind of
hated that name at the time
um because I thought and I it was
Charmed me that the um uh well it's its
logo was a was an implication sign
um and kind of the idea was that it was
sort of from the expert system side it
was going to all be about kind of being
able to encode knowledge in some kind of
logical form and to do things from it I
never believed in it I I never thought
it would work I never thought it would
be useful as it turned out that company
uh sort of not with my involvement
particularly uh did end up making use of
those kinds of Technologies on a number
of things building oh one of the I guess
the first kind of fraud detection system
for credit cards and things like uh
testing systems for NASA for for
spacecraft and things like this but in
any case that was kind of a
non-introduction for me to AI because
that was kind of in the expert systems
mode of things but I didn't really pay
attention to it and perhaps I even was a
little bit allergic to it because I
thought from a sort of corporate point
of view that it was taking things in the
wrong direction
so
I guess the the next thing that that
happened in my this is a long and Shaggy
story I thought this was very simple but
as I think about it it's not quite so
simple
um the next kind of big thing I suppose
that happened for me in in this regard
was um this must have been
uh 1981 or so I was interested in this
general question of how complex things
managed to happen in the world and what
kind of models one could construct for
that and I was kind of looking for what
was sort of foundational models that can
be used
and I ended up thinking of brains as
kind of one example of how complex
things happen potentially from the quote
simple components of things like neurons
and so I started reading a bunch of
things that have been written by people
like John Von Neumann
um and people like McCulloch and Pitts
and so on about neural Nets and I also
was kind of thinking well what's the
best way to represent kind of a minimal
model for kind of a bunch of components
interacting in some way I was also sort
of somewhat uh inspired by the ising
model model of spin systems invented in
the 1920s that was very sort of commonly
studied in physics by that time but in
any case the the result of this was I
think it must have been sometime maybe
early 1981 that I started working on
this kind of a raise of cells with
simple rules that determined the color
of a cell based on the colors of its
neighbors and I fairly quickly learned
that things like that at least I was I
was looking at the one-dimensional case
at least in the two-dimensional case
that things like that had been looked at
before and had been named cellular
automata and so that was kind of my my
uh the direction that I went in I had
originally thought of the thing I'd was
trying to study as being something that
we relevant to brains and neural Nets
and so on but cellular automata were a
lot simpler than neural Nets and I
really was pulled very much in the
direction of studying cellular automata
and realizing there was already
tremendous richness in cellular automata
and so I didn't it wasn't really worth
me sort of looking at neural Nets
because that was a more complicated case
so then
I suppose the next thing that I remember
happening in this Tangled tail was
perhaps 1982 I was at Caltech and maybe
it was 1981 still and a trap called John
hopfield uh was who'd been kind of a
physicist then biologist and so on had
was making a lot of noise out of this
kind of neural net that he'd created
that could kind of store memories
and that could be set up uh using
essentially the linear algebra kinds of
methods it could be sort of defined to
to store a memory and so I got
interested in this and it was something
where I kind of thought it might be
relevant to my kind of fuzzy hashing
idea and so on because it kind of had
this feature that you'd started off from
many possible initial States and it
would evolve kind of dissipatively
towards an attractor and where sort of
every initial state that was like a cat
would evolve to the cat attack to every
initial state that was like a dog would
evolve to the dog attractor I have to
say I I was a little bit frustrated
because I I did try and simulate these
networks and never quite got the same
answer as as hopfield got and I think I
asked him about it a couple of times but
I never really pursued what was going on
and and I think it had to do in in part
maybe with the way that uh well I don't
really know it could have been anything
from round off errors on
on computers and different ways of
evaluating things to different ways of
handling asynchronous updating of neuron
values and so on but in any case that
was a a uh you know I filled up a
notebook of kind of neural network kinds
of things but it didn't get very far at
that time
then I guess
uh I was
very concerned with
things like cellular automata where
really it was you give the program and
then something happens and you go and
analyze what happens more so than
anything that could quotes learn in a
particular way
but
I became friends with people like Terry
sanovsky and other people who were
trying to kind of rejuvenate the field
of neural Nets the field of neural Nets
initiated in 1943 they kind of Fallen
upon hard times in the 1960s largely as
a result of a book written by modern
minskin Seymour papert both of whom I
knew Martin's girl I knew fairly well
um that book called perceptrons had kind
of argued that well neural Nets at least
one layer neural Nets really couldn't do
anything interesting they could just
make sort of linear distinctions between
things and people kind of extrapolated
from that to say well then neural Nets
don't do anything interesting but back
around 1980 a group of people from
several kinds of disciplines are partly
physics partly biology partly psychology
had kind of ended up uh sort of saying
well actually know that there really are
things particularly if you have hidden
layers between kind of the initial input
layer and the output layer and so you
have multiple layers
um there are things that you can make
neural Nets do and so
I kind of was was aware of those things
going on I didn't I didn't get deeply
involved in it because I always thought
that I was interested in kind of the the
sort of fundamental science of how
complex Behavior happens and so on and I
felt there was still a lot further to
run on that kind of thing before one
dealt with kind of the case of brains
but uh
well I think
probably by
1985 1986
I had gotten more interested in how
would one essentially program a cellular
automaton how would one make a cellular
automaton do what one wants and that led
me to kind of these questions of whether
one could have it learn so to speak and
I wrote like one little paper uh talking
about kind of cellular automata with
extra kinds of bits that would be used
to specify their behavior and trying to
understand whether one could sort of
learn in that context it didn't work
very well and I kind of uh didn't pursue
that
well then gosh uh then I I started
working on what became Mathematica
and I really didn't think of that as
being an ai-ish kind of thing and AI as
a field had really Fallen upon Hard
Times by that point uh so this is now
the the end of the 1980s
uh and people really weren't talking
much about AI now people were
occasionally bringing up neural Nets
occasionally the term machine learning
would arise machine learning wasn't
really much of a thing then people would
uh uh would even quite quickly after the
emergence of Mathematica people started
building kind of simulated neural Nets
in Mathematica I never paid much
attention to them uh I really always
thought well it's very complicated and
mushy and I'm not sure that anything
interesting can come out of it
so then
uh what happened next well I went off
and uh uh by 1991 I was working on my
big book A New Kind of Science about
what simple programs typically do and in
that book I didn't talk much about
brains but I had a section about
perception and Analysis chapter 10. and
that really has to do with for me the
critical point was we have these very
simple programs and they seem to do very
complicated things what does it mean
seem to do very complicated things how
does that relate to kind of how we
perceive things and so on and and kind
of my point in that chapter was the
programs that we use for perception and
Analysis are themselves also simple
programs just like the simple programs
that we are using to generate this
behavior in the first place that's a
theme that uh many years later would now
come back in our physics project and
then talking about the rouliad and
talking about observers and so on but at
the time I was really in that chapter 10
I was really sort of cataloging the
types of perceptional analysis that one
could consider doing
and one of the sections there was
precisely about kind of brain-like
perception and I really talked again
about my kind of fuzzy uh hashing kind
of idea and kind of talked a little bit
about neural Nets and uh uh talked about
kind of this well really this this
notion of attractors as being a key part
of the process of perception something
that even now in The Observer theory
that I'm trying to build is something
that comes up yet again
but
I saw that section of my book as being
kind of just a you know dotting the eye
crossing the t how does this relate to
how brains perceive things
okay so I finished that book in 2002
and then I kind of got interested in
something that I had been interested in
since I was a kid which is how do you
organize kind of general knowledge about
the world when I was a kid I had kind of
collected and typed up all kinds of uh
documents about kind of uh organizing
information about all kinds of things
mostly about physics kinds of things but
uh I had I had always thought and this
had been something that had been in my
mind back in in 1979 1980 when I was
first kind of thinking about you know
could I extend the SMP idea to a brain
like thing could I take kind of
knowledge of the world and make it what
I would now say computable make it so
that one could kind of answer questions
on the basis of that knowledge
so every so often I would kind of
revisit that issue and I think I always
had the idea certainly I had that idea
in 1980
um that if one was going to make a
general thing that would kind of respond
to questions on the basis of knowledge
that's been accumulated by our
civilization that sort of the way to do
that would involve building what we
would Now call an AGI a sort of General
artificial intelligence that was kind of
brain like
so that was what I had believed for many
decades then I worked on my book new
kind of science introduced this idea of
the principle of computational
equivalence started realizing that I
couldn't make a sharp distinction
between the intelligent and the merely
computational
that there really wasn't a way to
distinguish you know the notion of the
weather has a mind of its own from we
humans have minds of Our Own
so then having having finished that work
and thinking again about this question
about kind of computational knowledge I
realized look if I believe my own
philosophy so to speak it must be the
case that this thing that you need to
build this computational knowledge
engine you need to build really has to
be something that can be achieved just
computationally without some spark of
Intelligence coming into it
I forgot a piece of the story here
back in
1984-85 I got involved with a company
that became called thinking machines
Corporation I think for my sins I I
actually suggested that name and in the
end I don't think it was a very good
name for the company but that was a
company that had spun out of MIT and its
kind of goal was to take for example a
theory that Marvin Minsky had had and to
sort of implement that theory of brains
in this thing called The Connection
machine computer which was intended to
be a massively parallel computer with 65
000 separate processing elements in the
end I used that machine and thought
about that machine mostly for studying
fluid dynamics with cellular automata I
invented a language called c-star that
never really made it very well it got
made rather more complicated than I had
imagined it
um that was a language that was an
extension of C for doing parallel
programming and so on but I didn't
really think of it as being a sort of a
a brain-like machine even though that
had been sort of its origins in this
theory of Marvin's and I
kind of uh I really was was much more
concerned about it as this thing with a
hypercube where you could route messages
from here to there but that was another
sort of exposure that I had to sort of
the the the the the the the aspirations
of AI and uh I had gotten to know folks
like Marvin Minsky who were uh very much
sort of in the in the AI Direction
um I have to say you know Marvin had
given me books like like he'd written
this book called Society of Mind he gave
me a draft of that book
um I couldn't really make anything of it
it was it just seemed like a bunch of
kind of uh uh sort of cute aphorisms
about how brains might work and I didn't
really it didn't really I didn't really
engage properly with it
um I think Marvin had originally
intended to write that book in verse and
I think got talked out of doing that
um as it was it was kind of a one idea
per page type book
um and uh and for me the ideas didn't
really didn't really uh sort of engage
particularly
so anyway but back to 2002 and and so on
um I uh by about 2004 2005 I was kind of
in this
thinking about
could one make kind of a computational
knowledge engine and what would it take
to do it and I realized if I believe my
own theories it better be something that
can be achieved just with computation
without sort of a magic of a brain-like
thing by the way I should say back in
the days of thinking machines uh one of
the things that had been kind of the the
concept behind that company was you know
can one invent the transistor of
artificial intelligence
I remember one of the investors in that
company uh talking about you know if
there's a one in a million chance to uh
invent the transistor of artificial
intelligence then this is a good
investment and I kind of rather jadedly
said I wonder how long it'll be before
he's banging his fist on the table
saying you know where's the revenue the
answer was about 18 months
um but in no case the uh that was kind
of a a thing and I think I was uh
somewhat of that same mindset that with
my fuzzy matching ideas and all this
kind of thing I imagined that there was
some poor idea some sort of transistor
of artificial intelligence like idea
that would sort of unlock things
anyway back to Mid
ought so to speak and
I was that point saying okay if building
a computational knowledge engine just
requires computation we have this great
computation stack with what was then
Mathematica now of language
uh so let's just try and build it and so
we got started building what became
wolfen Alpha
and a big part of that was solving the
natural language understanding problem
and
we needed to have something which could
take kind of natural language however
people said things and turn it into our
computational language from which we
could compute
and at first I kind of imagined well I
can learn things from computational
Linguistics I can learn things from
things that have been done in AI in the
past and
we tried but we really didn't and we
ended up just building our own kind of
from scratch kind of way of
understanding how natural language
understanding for uh sort of short
fragments could be done and it really
helped us that we uh kind of were able
to
uh we we had a target people had said
well in the past people had said well
let's just understand natural language
but the problem was it wasn't clear what
understand meant for us it was very
clear it meant convert it into
computational language and then be able
to compute from it you know as I'm as
I'm uh talking to to you guys I'm uh I'm
remembering a few other things
back in the in the 1980s there's sort of
still been kind of buzzings of AI and
there was kind of the there was the
expert system strand there was the more
kind of uh uh sort of learning kind of
Strand and I remember having various
experiences of being exposed to kind of
the AI as mystical kind of force type
type side of things and being deeply
unimpressed
so for example there was one time I
visited uh I think was Yale actually
um and uh visited some group that was
doing AI and uh they they uh they told
me
oh we have this technology this must
have been
1983 for maybe five
um we have this technology that
translates stories from Spanish into
English
at that time that was a totally science
fiction thing to be able to do that was
something maybe in you know 2001 or in
Star Trek that was a thing but in terms
of real technology that just wasn't a
thing that was possible people had
imagined that machine translation might
be sort of quite easy to do back in the
1960s but it hadn't worked out that way
so it was it was very surprising to me
and I'm like okay that sounds great let
me try it they were like um uh you know
and I said I don't know much Spanish but
let me see what I can type in so to
speak I said well no you don't
understand it it has to be you know a
whole story that you're translating and
so obviously I'm asking well how long
does a story have to be what's the
what's the minimal length of a story and
saying well you know it's um and uh
anyway we go through a whole series of
kind of well can it be this can it be
that and eventually what becomes clear
is it has to be stories of a particular
type well actually it's not just stories
of a particular type it's a particular
story that was supposed to be translated
from Spanish and English and I'm like
this is crazy what is this what are you
doing it's uh uh and you know their
explanation was well we're trying to
understand the structure of the Spanish
and how it Maps under the structure of
the English but the problem was for me
the distance between the original claim
and the actuality was so great that it
really you know cast a bad shadow over
things people might have been saying
about AI
I think the um
the other thing that I should have
mentioned is uh lisp was a language that
was very much wound up with AI John
McCarthy who invented the term
artificial intelligence and developed
lisp starting in the late 1950s a very
kind of visionary Direction in language
design although it was hard to actually
Implement and practice and in fact
people had built things like list
machines and in fact the list the
company list machines Incorporated was
various in various ways wound up with
the the company that I started uh that
were at least the merged version of the
company that I started
um and uh so there have been sort of
lisp had been kind of in the air
and uh it it didn't help that there was
a certain degree of kind of playful
non-sciencism that uh sort of seemed to
float around all things AI in those days
I mean I remember this must have been
1979 1980 uh I was developing SMP I had
organized a group of a collection of
seminars about kind of uh how one might
do math by computer and other kinds of
things like that and I was inviting
people who had worked on similar things
before and there was a chap from
Berkeley
um who came down to LA to Caltech uh one
day and uh we were giving this talk
and uh he was talking about some kind of
things lisp and was talking about oh
they have the system and it's called
Franz and it's kind of like asking the
audience why is it called France
well it's a lisp system and that kind of
is like the the composer list you know
fans list and so on well I happen to be
uh dick Feynman happened to be in the
audience I happened to be sitting next
to him and uh dick Feynman kind of stood
up at that moment and said if this is
what computer science is about it's all
nonsense
and uh and kind of stormed out uh
causing a a very long term I would say
uh uh kind of
um uh the person had been giving that
talk kind of blamed me for that
situation I think and um uh had a very
long-term Grudge about it but in any
case the um the point was that in
in those days this kind of we've got
this playful hacky you know cute sort of
thing that wraps around AI was really
very common and to me it was rather
off-putting uh it was kind of like well
tell me what is really going on what's
the real Point here what can you really
say what can you not say and so on uh
perhaps I would have a different
attitude today but um uh in in those
days it was it was sort of frustrating
it was like where's the meat show me
some meat you know don't give me puns
don't give me kind of uh sort of fake
versions of of claims and so on just
show me the actual meat and I never saw
the meat in those days
but any case back in 2009 when we
released wolf malpha uh we had succeeded
in doing really quite good natural
language understanding targeting more
from language as the thing that it was
understood to and being able to answer
all kinds of questions
you know one thing that was sort of an
indication of of the way that field
developed
was uh it was a couple of weeks before
Wolfram Alpha was released I was at some
event and Marvin Minsky was there and I
said to Marvin you know I have this
question answering system which we've
built and you should look at it it's
it's pretty cool
and so
you know I opened up my computer and I
started off and Marvin comes a little
excited for a few seconds and then kind
of changes the subject to some wild
thing that he liked to talk about
and I was like uh you know no Marvin you
should actually look at this
and you know because it works you know
it's a real thing and so he looks at it
starts typing things in and starts
typing more things in and then he's like
oh my God it actually works and you know
he's going off and telling all the other
people at this event that same thing so
for him kind of he'd seen a zillion
question answering systems I'd seen a
bunch of question answering systems and
they were all I would say very very lame
they really didn't work they had been
often built using kind of the AIS
tradition
of kind of let's use I I think what
happened was that there was a sort of a
strange merger of a belief that logic
expressed everything about the world
that you could encode the whole world in
terms of logic
that there was something sort of
psychological that needed to be
represented in AIM and I remember asking
Marvin a few years later he was writing
a book I think was called the emotion
machine
and I said what is this that you are
writing Marvin what kind of a thing is
it is it kind of a thing like a theory
of psychology like a Freud or something
like this is it a thing that's like kind
of computer science and like a
prescription for how computers do things
you know what kind of a thing is it and
I think at that time he said well if
it's any of these things it's something
more like a kind of theory of psychology
but there was a sort of a strange
mixture of kind of the uh sort of
theories of psychology together with uh
uh kind of Primacy of logic which is
very different from that
um together with a certain degree of
sort of cute hackery that seem to be
kind of part of the the main AI stick
and then quite separately there was the
the let's use neural Nets to build
practical things and I don't think I
knew at the time that things like
optical character recognition OCR
methods that were being developed were
all really based on neural Nets maybe I
knew that at the time but I don't think
so and to me those were just oh it's a
random algorithm
I remember actually this must have been
uh
2010 2011 even 2010 perhaps I was
interested in in what we could do in in
image recognition
um we had uh it must have been whenever
the Fukushima nuclear accident was it
was it was shortly after that because we
had done kind of an emergency project
for an organization that uh ended up
consisting of looking at Satellite
photographs and trying to identify cars
on roads and where there were cars and
where there weren't cars
um in in the region of that accident and
so on and so I'd gone kind of realized
that the way we identified cars was
using sort of hacky image processing
techniques and there was similarly no
one kind of hacky image processing
techniques for doing things like finding
faces and images and so I sort of
wondered given that in Wolf malfo we'd
curated all these different kinds of
knowledge about the world I wondered
could we curate kind of the
the the sort of knowledge of what pieces
of image processing one would have to do
to find you know windows and a picture
of a house or find uh cell boundaries in
a pathology image or or some such other
thing and I kind of imagine there might
be a couple of hundred of these kinds of
types of objects that were worth looking
for in pictures and I kind of was was
all ready to start building kind of a
pipeline where people would sort of
construct these image processing hacks
to find all these different kinds of
things and I remember asking
teresanovsky neural net friend of mine
right at that time you know what can we
do is there something is there something
better we can do with this and he was
like well I don't really know you know
things you know there are particular
examples where you can use particular
neural Nets to do this stuff and that
was right before the whole Alex Nat
story with Terry's friend Jeff Hinton
and so on and this uh realization that
as it happened deep neural Nets could be
successful at identifying objects just
from training without sort of building
that hacky image processing kind of
thing and it certainly when that
happened there were sort of very quickly
sort of the uh the kind of the big rumor
from Silicon Valley of oh my gosh neural
Nets have now worked
um you know behind the scenes that was
uh you know Google buying Jeff hinton's
kind of pop-up company and things like
this
uh but you know that got me to kind of
look at these things again and realize
oh yeah actually there's some stuff
that's starting to work here and and
then we got involved a person called
talibanon who uh uh long time person at
our company
um kind of said we've got to build a
machine learning pipeline for uh Forum
language
um and so we very quickly started uh
constructing what is now our whole
symbolic neural on that framework
um within the language
um and uh that was but that must have
been 2012 2013 something like that
so
those are um
so I mean and then we kind of were on
the modern path but I would say that
that in the previous period
things
uh you know whatever I sort of heard
about neural Nets it was always oh
they're very mushy and complicated and
you know they're a thing that has a sort
of uh an era of mystery about them they
reminded me a lot of global minimization
global optimization you know when you
are trying to find you have a
mathematical function for example and it
Wiggles around you're trying to find
where's the minimum of that function
question is there are techniques for for
saying well I'm I'm close to a minimum
let me home in on the on the final
minimum and just sort of descend along
the gradient vector and so on to get
there
but the big question is can you find the
global minimum of such a function and
back when we first started developing
Mathematica back in 1986 and so on but
certainly a question could we put in a
function called you know minimize that
would just find the minimum value
function but it just seemed completely
implausible to me it just seemed like
there was no sort of way to be reliable
in doing that but then people would come
regularly and they would tell us we've
got to you know we've got this magic
sort of black magic Black Box function
that just minimizes any any function and
I would never believe it and some of
those things were a little bit neural
net oriented and but they had the same
sort of flavor as people saying I've got
this neural Netty thing that does
Something Magic and we can't really
explain what's going on
many years later the techniques for
function minimization kind of got I
would say robust enough that even though
they're not perfect they become a thing
that's useful enough that one can put
them into our language and people can
rely on them uh at least as long as
their functions aren't too too weird and
crazy but in any case that was sort of
you know the the thing I'm trying to
communicate is that there was this kind
of yes neural network thing but they
were kind of mushy and mysterious and
occasionally people would claim that
they were doing things with them but it
wasn't really they were they were really
one-off kinds of things I remember uh
trap called Robert heck Nielsen who had
kind of a a particular sort of approach
to neural Nets he had a company it was
making I think they made fraud detection
uh software in the end but it was just
very unclear to me what was really going
on there I mean to what extent uh it
didn't help that there were techniques
that would sometimes not very often get
described as being machine learning but
that was really a sort of disreputable
term but more often it would be like oh
we're doing some kind of regression
we're doing something that's part of
statistics and but it wasn't very clear
to what extent the things that were sort
of neural Nets and it's like brains and
the things that were statistics and it's
like math how those really related to
each other and that didn't become clear
I would say until really recent times
and there were a bunch of kind of
competing methodologies that were uh
kind of those self-organizing maps and
uh
oh boy what other kinds of things
various kinds of trees and but came
random forests and so on and various
other kinds of um oh I'm forgetting
there were three or four other methods
that were all things that were sort of
part of the the toolbox of can you sort
of magically make a model for data and
and by the way one of the things that
again suffused this this whole area uh
for me was people saying we've got this
way to make a model for data and it
worked for any data and it's a modelist
model there were a bunch of things
around the maximum entropy method which
uh which were again sort of had the vibe
of being modelist models you just throw
this this machine at anything and it
will make a model that allows you to
make predictions about that thing and I
I just I found that very very
unconvincing because I kind of knew that
anytime you're extrapolating beyond what
you've actually seen you implicitly have
to have some kind of model of what's
plausible and even though people could
say well our model is that it's really
it's always plausible that our model
will do something plausible it really
didn't make sense it really was
something where there was sort of a a
recursive you you hadn't sort of
grounded the recursion to say what the
the model that you were using to model
was really based on and so that always
caused me a lot of trouble when people
were telling me about these kinds of
techniques
so that's a little bit of that's a a
rather long and Shaggy story about um uh
my kind of uh personal history with
what's now called AI uh I would say that
sort of if you project backwards a lot
of things that I've done that relates to
kinds of mathematical computation and
things like that with things that back
when I was first involved in these
things people would say if you can only
do that we know we have true AI so to
speak
um and uh uh yeah I mean I think there
are other pieces to this I mean I I I I
have to say I I I know I collected lots
of the literature of AI going back many
years uh from the Alan Turing 1950 kind
of thing about AI to lots of other
things and oh yeah another another piece
to this gosh I'm sorry I I it's these
things tumble out of my memory as I
start thinking about this there was a
whole nother tradition of brain like
studies that was essentially physicists
generalizing things like the icing model
two neural Nets and asking what their
kind of physics-like analysis would be
um there was a chap uh chap called
Gordon Shore a chap called uh
and yellow I think various people who
were who were kind of uh who did things
that to me were actually more appealing
they were kind of more this was 1980s
again they were more kind of science
like uh but they didn't really get that
far they were able to say well you know
we have this thing and it's like kind of
a bulk neural net and what does it do we
don't really know what it does there
were people as chap called Jack Cowan at
University of Chicago who was studying
things like kind of bulk depolarization
waves on the brain for things like
epilepsy and things like the overall
mapping of kind of a visual image on the
retina onto the brain these were these
were again more in the tradition of kind
of uh physics and Mathematics like
analyzes of of brain-like things
and I think that was that was a kind of
another thing that I used to sort of
follow and I collected papers on it and
things like this there weren't that many
papers about these kinds of things but
somehow this stuff it never really the
the the connection between those things
and the things that I was able to do in
technology the things that I was doing
in science with cellular automata they
never really all quite connected and
it's only in very recent times that I
think we can sort of see a bunch of that
connection come to pass uh it sort of uh
um and anyway that that's um a long
answer to what seemed like a simple
question there
um
let's see
uh the question from Ian have I yet seen
the movie that's coming out about
Oppenheimer I have not I hope to see it
I think it isn't out at least in my
Suburban part of the world yet but I
hope to see it uh in a few days
um I will say that I knew many people
who had worked at the Manhattan Project
um and uh it was it was sort of
interesting to see its role in the
history of physics
because you know the Manhattan Project
was taking place in the early 1940s and
I was getting involved in physics in the
mid-1970s
so but many of the people who've been
involved in the Manhattan Project have
been young people at the time when they
were involved
and there was somehow this certain
Mystique that seemed to sort of be
around the physicists who've been
involved in Manhattan Project I'm not
sure that everything about the Manhattan
Project had been Declassified yet by the
time uh I was sort of first encountering
these people so perhaps there was a
little bit of uh you know person a knows
what person B did but can't tell anybody
else about it but there was a there was
a Mystique kind of a glow of they'd done
something important and they'd also been
part of this kind of uh uh kind of um
small sort of uh uh Brotherhood build or
something of people who had um uh who
had been involved in in that project
I would say that
I uh started uh I was a consultant at
Los Alamos in the early 1980s I think
when I first went there Los Alamos was
still a town that didn't appear on maps
it was something where you know Drive
North from Santa Fe in New Mexico and
you'll get to Los Alamos but you don't
see it on the map
um and uh
so that was kind of exotic
but uh
a lot of the people some of the people
who've been involved in the Manhattan
Project were still at Los Alamos at the
time I was a consultant there but much
of that group had sort of become a
diaspora going off to different
universities in some cases going back to
different universities
I mean I remember uh one person I mean
there were many people who'd been
involved in the Manhattan Project who I
encountered I mean dick Feynman was one
person I knew fairly well he'd been
involved as sort of the head of the of
the human computer project so to speak
because in those days they weren't there
weren't yet electronic computers it was
they were mechanical computers
calculators but there was sort of a pool
of people who computed things the
climbing was really a very good uh human
who calculated things and he was
probably a very appropriate person to be
leading the kind of the pool of people
who would actually calculate things by
hand and say this is the result for this
kind of I don't know uh uh kind of
detonation wave or whatever else it was
and certainly dick Feynman told me a
bunch of stories about the Manhattan
Project
um you know he
he told me about seeing the first bomb
test and kind of the the feeling that he
had after that that my gosh the world's
just going to blow itself up and you
know uh seeing people kind of building
things and and wondering you know what's
the point of building these things the
world's just going to blow itself up uh
although he kind of got over that after
a while
he also told me about the um uh the
moment
when they were trying to work out would
would
setting off the first nuclear explosion
ignite the atmosphere would it start uh
leading to a reaction in which the
oxygen in the atmosphere would basically
burn and uh and the whole atmosphere
would be uh would have an exothermic
reaction and destroy all life on Earth
and uh he was like
told me at least he was like come you
know we're pretty sure that wouldn't
happen we kind of got convinced that
wouldn't happen and so the bomb test
happened so to speak and fortunately it
didn't ignite the atmosphere but of
course of those days one didn't really
know for sure it was very hard to
predict that for certain
um I think you know fireman's team of of
calculators was part of the the workflow
of trying to work out would would it
ignite the atmosphere I think um G.I
Taylor was another person who was much
involved in that a fluid dynamicist who
I oh I don't think I ever met
um but who
was famous for kind of making use of
dimensional analysis as a way to sort of
do a back of the envelope calculation
about what would happen in uh in nuclear
explosions and managing to get it more
or less right
but uh uh
you know Feynman told me other stories
about some Los Alamos many other stories
he was very impressed by Oppenheimer by
the way he thought Oppenheimer was a
very impressive sort of uh kind of
outsized leader a person who could kind
of um uh get people to do things in a in
a very effective way so to speak
I think uh uh there were other kind of
side shows to the Manhattan Project
uh it was a chap called Klaus Fuchs who
turned up eventually was a uh turned out
eventually to be a a Russian spy
but who was uh
um kind of involved in the British
nuclear effort and then worked at Los
Alamos and and Dick Feynman told me a
bunch of stories about what he sort of
realized after the facts fact was kind
of Klaus Fuchs trying to sort of sound
him out on his views about communism and
so on
um I have to say that when I I worked uh
back in 1976 briefly after I left High
School I worked at a British government
lab called the Rutherford lab which was
kind of next door to Harwell which was
the um British atomic energy research
establishment
um that was a nuclear uh
well it was Nuclear Physics let's say
there was a separate place that was the
ultimate weapons development lab but um
at Harwell house folks have been the
head of the theory division there and uh
you know he'd eventually sort of come
out as a spy and um uh when I was
working there in 1976 there was still
definitely a very long Shadow being cast
um over the operation and the sort of
the theory group there by the fact that
its leader had turned out to be a
Russian spy
but in any case the um but back to the
Manhattan Project
um I think the thing that um
uh there were a couple of things that
were very obvious in the in the kind of
American physics environment that were
kind of uh holdovers from that Manhattan
Project one of the most important was
that
sort of the physicists had done
something
sort of great for the war effort
and it wasn't obvious that anything like
that would happen it wasn't obvious that
sort of the somewhat abstract physicists
would deliver something as major as
nuclear weapons
you know Engineers have been working on
radar and that had been a thing that was
impressive
but sort of this was a a great big kind
of wow
for physicists
in um
in their contribution to kind of the the
the war effort and so on and I think
there was a certain feeling that the
government kind of owed the physics
Community as a result of the Manhattan
Project that the Manhattan Project had
just done something remarkable for the
government that uh uh that somehow
needed to be repaid to the physics
community and I think that what happened
in the development of particle physics
after the second World War I always saw
that as being a kind of long thank you
from the US government to the physics
Community for the Manhattan Project and
it was kind of a thing where uh the you
know particle accelerators what were
they going to make were they going to
lead to something that was sort of a a
new generation of military important
thing or were they just basic science
most people thought they were just basic
science
famous quote from Robert Wilson who is a
guy who built up fermilab being asked
you know what was the significance of
fermilab for uh the defense of the
United States it was asked that in some
Congressional testimony and he famously
said uh you know it doesn't contribute
anything to the defense of the United
States but it's part of what makes the
United States worth defending
um that was a sort of a and at the time
that was I think said probably in the
late 1960s maybe early 1970s that was a
uh that that seemed like a very valid
thing to be to be saying
um I think that uh
the the kind of the long thank you for
the Manhattan Project kind of lasted
until really the mid-1990s
and that was when the people who've been
involved in the Manhattan Project were
retiring and so on and uh and kind of at
all there was another generation of
physicists
and the the sort of the last test of the
thank you for the Manhattan Project
was the superconducting Super collider
project this big thing that was
eventually to be located in Texas sort
of the the great new American particle
accelerator I forget how much it was
going to cost probably on the other 10
billion dollars
um and uh it was kind of like was this
going to be a uh was this going to be a
thing that was worth the government
supporting and it felt like kind of the
the glow for Manhattan Project was sort
of dying off
and it felt like there was a problem
there and and what had happened within
the physics Community itself the
condensed matter physicists uh were
feeling they were more important you
know they've been involved with the
transistor and superconductivity and
things like this it's like why are all
the particle physicists getting all this
money we want some of it too although
they didn't have as as much to spend it
on it's only in modern times was kind of
the rise of the story of quantum
Computing that there's been kind of a a
big ticket thing that uh sort of
condensed matter physics could uh could
be part of but anyway at the time
I remember the supposed to be in
mid-1990s I remember being at some
dinner at fermilab uh with the then
director Leon Letterman and uh there was
the sort of the next day was going to be
this big vote about the super collider
uh in Congress and I spent the whole
dinner trying to trying to convince Leon
that he should come up with a quote
like the Robert Wilson quote that would
be remembered if the vote went against
the super collider that it would be
remembered at a time when sort of people
were thinking again about spending large
amounts of money on basic research in
the particle physics Direction I I
completely failed to uh to convince
um Leon uh to come up with some some
poetic quotes so to speak and in the end
I don't remember what was said but it
was nothing very good when as one kind
of thought was going to happen the vote
went against the super collider and uh
and the project was killed
but um I think then sort of another
piece of the Manhattan Project story
uh
well I mean I I am
I I knew Stan ulam who was also quite
involved in the Manhattan Project and um
the uh I guess more so in the hydrogen
bomb then no actually I I'm I'm taking
that back I think
that the implosion lands idea which is
critical to the operation of of nuclear
weapons was a
um
I'm now forgetting this this was I think
that was uh teller Edward Teller and
Stan Olam uh were sort of The
Originators of that
um and uh uh
I think I knew standard I'm very late in
his life when perhaps um uh it was a
little different than what he had been
like earlier on
but um
then another sort of piece of the uh of
the consequences of the Manhattan
Project
were that that Oppenheimer after the
Manhattan Project
um Oppenheimer
I think was uh the next sort of big
question was okay there's there's this
sort of powerful thing that's been
created with nuclear weapons and who
should say what will happen with this
and Oppenheimer and quite a lot of the
other physicists were like well we
physicists should have a say in this you
know it's too important to be left to
the politicians and so that that became
quite a kind of push to with things like
you know pug wash and the um Union of
concern scientists in the union of it
what was it um oh gosh bulletin of the
atomic scientists and so on a whole
collection of uh kind of essentially
activism on the part of physicists and
so on to kind of have a real say in what
should happen with the thing that they
in a sense intellectually had created
and I think that Oppenheimer was
involved in that and the whole question
the questions about what would happen
with the hydrogen bomb I think it didn't
help that the the Soviet Union uh
perhaps in large part through the
efforts of Klaus folks had um uh you
know was rather quick to be able to have
their own uh
atomic bomb and so on and that sort of
created this uh this climate of tension
um about what was going to happen
and perhaps in the middle of all of that
Oppenheimer who was by all accounts a a
sort of forceful uh if Brash kind of
character
um sort of ran a foul of the kind of
political forces and ended up getting
sort of attacked for his connections to
Communism and so on I mean it was sort
of a I think you know that had been a a
very typical thing for many people in
that orbit you know Oppenheimer had
worked in Berkeley uh which was sort of
a place where where there was a lot of
interest in those kinds of things in the
1930s and so on I mean I think that the
Manhattan Project was was a bit bimodal
in in terms of some of the people
working there there have been people
who'd uh come out of uh kind of a lot of
people who'd come out of the Nazi
Germany story people who by the end of
the war were seeing kind of the uh uh
the the Russians as a kind of a a
negative Force so to speak and I think
it was kind of a um you know are you are
you for the Soviet Union or are you
against the Soviet Union and some people
were were really for it and some people
were very against it
um but I think that uh but anyway what
what happened was that um Oppenheimer
got sort of attacked and the the big
drama was that he lost his security
clearance so to speak and um one of the
things that had been sort of set up uh
in the aftermath of um of the Manhattan
Project was the atomic energy commission
and it was sort of a a big deal to be a
commissioner in the atomic energy
commission for example John Von Neumann
was a commissioner in atomic energy
commission and when uh the one little
video snippet that exists from a from a
strange television program uh where Von
Neiman is interacting with a bunch of
kids the uh the thing that he's
introduced as being is a commissioner in
the atomic energy Commission and that
was sort of the most significant uh
attribute that he had at that time uh
it's kind of an irony of history that as
we look at sort of AI and it's um uh its
effect on the world that there's sort of
a a certain call which I don't
necessarily agree with
um to sort of create something that's
sort of a regulatory entity uh like the
atomic energy commission that will no
doubt have its AI Commissioners and so
on
um to be to be part of it I mean it's of
course to be said that the supply chain
of making a nuclear weapon is
unbelievably much more difficult and
complicated than the supply chain for
making an AI
um so it's a rather different kind of
story in terms of what's uh what can be
managed in what way in the world but any
case the result of Oppenheimer kind of
leaving the atomic energy world was that
he was placed at The Institute for
advanced study as its director
and the institute for brand study have
been created in the early 1930s and as
scientists ended up leaving Germany in
the 1930s uh it had accumulated an
impressive roster of folks from Albert
Einstein to Kurt girdle who hadn't left
quite for those reasons but but uh
onward um John Von Neiman other people
um and so it must have been um oh gosh
in the in the sometime in the 1950s
Oppenheimer sort of arrived to be the
director of The Institute for advanced
study
um and uh uh he I think he died in 1968
give or take
um and I
um
was worked at the interpretive on study
back well maybe he maybe he died later
than that maybe he died in the 70s
um I think maybe he came I'm I'm losing
track of the dates here in any case when
when I worked to the insurance Pro
Advanced study which was starting in
about 1983
um the it was sort of interesting
because there was still kind of vestiges
of
sort of imprints of of oppenheimer's
work there in particular Oppenheimer I
think rather impressively had hired a
whole collection of uh sort of promising
young physicists to work at The
Institute and he had done kind of
somewhat high risk but High payoff
hiring and so the dynamic that happened
that was a surely an unanticipated and
maybe I don't know by him uh was that by
the time I was there you know they had
all these all these sort of high-risk
hirings and and many of those people had
sort of paid off spectacularly and done
amazing things in physics but most of
those people had over the years kind of
wandered off onto other opportunities in
other parts of the world and so kind of
the the part of the risk equation that
Oppenheimer had initiated that um uh was
the ones where they hadn't quite been
oriented or their lives hadn't worked
out in such a way that they could really
really do the amazing things in physics
those people were still there and and it
often was was something where you would
think well it's kind of a good deal to
be just told you can just go think about
science and nothing else for the rest of
your life but it turns out that that
isn't actually necessarily such a good
deal and that was kind of an interesting
and and in some cases not uh not very
positive human stories so to speak
well let's see
uh
gosh I probably once I've seen this
movie I might have more to say about
um some of the characters who are
portrayed in it I I don't know um who
all will be um uh will be presented in
that in that movie I think um
um
I am
uh or
you know I
it was as I say quite interesting that
there will be people where there was
this kind of Mystique
and sort of uh oh this person has done
something amazing uh sort of Aura around
people at the end of the by the end at
the end of the 70s but it wasn't so
clear what those things were I mean like
I remember there was a guy called Bob
backer
um who's a physicist at Caltech where I
sort of always knew had done something
notable but I never really knew what I
haven't looked up even today what maybe
he'll be in the movie and I'll find out
um but uh uh and there were
uh it was it was always
you know as I say it was always this
kind of um
um this sort of
um
this kind of collection of people who
were involved in something great
together and that left kind of a glow
behind I see the same thing today
um in uh people who've been involved in
a in all sorts of startups and
discoveries and things like this that
there's there's always this um this kind
of thing about people who are involved
in something that turned into something
big
Um Manhattan Project being a a
particularly extreme example of that
um
let's see
uh
yeah I can find one more thing and then
I should uh go on my way here
um
there's an interesting question but I
don't know if I can answer it easily
from prab have new scientific
discoveries historically initiated out
of myths
it's an interesting question
there are often things that people kind
of vaguely believe are true
and only much later does it become
established what's scientifically true
then there are things where people
believe it's true and
the science never really comes
I mean an example of one which who knows
maybe the science will yet come is
things like you know extra sensory
perception can there be sort of
communication from brain to brain by
some mechanism other than sort of Sight
and Sound and so on
um that's one of those kinds of things
where you might uh you know if something
comes of that it will be a thing where
there was almost sort of a myth that
this worked
um and uh and then it became science I'm
trying to think
there are things about science where
it's just like uh kind of totally
surprising that it works
x-rays might have been an example of
that there might have been
myths in the past where it's kind of
like people can see through things and
maybe that would play into kind of this
is uh uh this is what x-rays are but
really the discovery of something like
x-rays was just a a total surprise
now you know there are
uh
there are things where it's like you
know drink the elixir of eternal life
and good things will happen type thing
and you know if one day some sort of uh
uh uh approach to kind of human
longevity emerges that is just you know
drink this Elixir
um then it will feel like that myth
turned into reality I think the uh uh
and and perhaps there's almost a
tendency to say you know drink the
pomegranate juice it'll be just like the
myth kind of thing and that that myth
has kind of an overhang in our view of
what might be true scientifically
you know there are certainly things from
Antiquity that are kind of sort of
things people have said and then they
turn out to be true like for example
famous one is it was Troy a historical
City or was it just something made up in
in The Iliad by by Homer so to speak and
it became in the in the 1800s it turned
out well Troy was actually real you know
something like Atlantis
City I think people like
Cicero maybe talks about that as you
know a city covered under the ocean so
to speak but had been a a remarkable
city of all kinds that that is thought
today to be sort of a myth but maybe
there's actually something to be
discovered one day that there will be
actually a city under the ocean that
will show up now along those lines
Cicero I think described
something that was kind of a calculating
device and for centuries nobody knew
what on Earth that could be until the
anti-cathera device was discovered well
it was first found in the in a shipwreck
around 1900 but it was first kind of
figured out sort of what it was by the
1960s and then in more detail by the by
the 1990s and 2000s that it was a
mechanical calculating device kind of a
an original computer so to speak so in
that sense that was something that had
not quite been a myth but it had been a
thing sort of said as a matter of kind
of almost philosophical rhetoric that
then turned out later to be something
real
I think the uh uh this well there are
certainly
ideas
that
one can say originate
in things like theology that then sort
of play into things that one realizes
are relevant today like for example one
of the things that is quite relevant in
one woman thinks about things like AI
ethics is what does it take for things
to have free will and what has Free Will
and what doesn't what can be responsible
for its actions what what isn't and your
own Christian theology the idea that
Free Will was a thing for people that
people could make their own decisions
was something that was was developed
there and but yet there was this other
branch which was kind of but then there
were Angels where it's kind of decided
for in advance are they good or evil and
that kind of plays into the kind of well
we have a machine and it has kind of a a
set of rules which decide in advance in
some sense good or evil and so that's
kind of you know what started as a story
of theology uh has a certain at least
kind of concept connection to the things
that were now confronted as a matter of
kind of things like AI ethics
but I think I'm trying to think about
other kind of um
myths that turned into reality I suppose
I'm thinking about them kind of uh Greek
myths of um
um
many of which were kind of attempts to
explain the world or myths from the
Bible things like this where there was
sort of attempts to explain the world so
so for example
um
one I suppose that's interesting is some
uh something like things in in Genesis
where it's kind of like and then there
are these creatures around in the world
and then they have to be given names
and this kind of idea of sort of how
does language evolve and later things
like the Tower of Babel and so on how is
it that language comes to be how is it
that these things are just there in the
world and then we give them names and
that kind of humanizes them that's sort
of an interesting kind of in in that
presentation a kind of mythical idea
which then sort of plays into kind of
what does it mean for us to identify
things in the world and give them names
and so on so perhaps there's a there's a
correspondence there I don't think we
quite and perhaps you know the Tower of
Babel we can start thinking about you
know is there as we see sort of the
embeddings in an AI and we see that
there's sort of a what we see
computational language we see that
there's an underlying structure of
meaning that then has its different
manifestations in the different human
languages of the world and one could
sort of play into that that into kind of
this idea that there was at one time a
universal language which then kind of
split into the particular languages of
of uh of the people of the earth so to
speak so those are a few kind of
correspondences one might imagine there
I'm trying to think whether there are
kind of discoveries that um
who originated that way there were
certainly drivers of that kind of thing
for example the long-time alchemical
idea that there should be a way to turn
lead into gold which didn't work out as
such as a matter of chemistry but
certainly drove a lot of attempts to
turn this into that so to speak and led
to lots of kinds of things in chemistry
I suppose um uh well okay another thing
that one could identify along the same
lines and this is kind of from uh that
originates in many cultures is this idea
of sort of the immortal Soul as a an
element of something like a brain that
isn't the material of a brain but is
some kind of thing that is the
significant engram of a brain but not
the brain itself that was something that
certainly existed across many cultures
and it's something which
uh uh until recently it just wasn't
clear what on Earth that could could
sort of meaningfully be and and one sort
of wondered and people would sort of
mock kind of this idea of well you know
is there a soul you know if the soul
leaves the body on death does that mean
the body gets to be to weigh less
because there's something that sort of
departed and so on and uh uh then one
realized that actually the notion of a
soul is really very much like the
abstract idea of computation it's kind
of a a computational representation of
what's going on in a mind
abstracted from the material details of
neurons and and uh electrical firings
and all this kind of thing so it's
something which in some sense was there
all along for thousands of years in a
variety of different uh across many
cultures many Traditions it was a thing
but really nobody understood what it was
now I think we do understand what it is
it wasn't that was not the causative
that wasn't sort of the causal
progression of people understanding this
idea of computation and maybe it's
relationship to things like AI it wasn't
that that came from Souls but I think
there's sort of a convergence in in that
I think
gosh I'm trying to think about other
other kinds of of myths and so on
um I think uh uh I should probably um
depart here before I let me think is
there anything else I can think of that
is um
kind of um
you know these are not myths but many of
the things that you know Aristotle tried
to talk about about his kind of theory
of the way the world works the way the
mind works and so on
um many of those things
were at first well actually let's talk
about a different thing
you know in ancient Greek philosophy
there was very much the idea of let's
just by pure thought imagine how the
world must work
and
let's kind of
develop this idea that there might be
atoms and there might be the void and so
on
I think
this idea it's not quite the same myth
with a story so to speak there's not a
personality a human personality involved
in that which seems to be typical of
many kinds of myths but it is uh
something where there was kind of a a
kind of a story that was getting told
about how the world exists which
eventually turned into science but it
took a couple of thousand years
I think
the um
um I'm trying to think about
kind of other
sorts of things and it's often very
difficult when you have something which
is described in kind of everyday terms
in some sort of mythical terms and then
later on a piece of science gets done
that kind of a little bit reminds one of
that myth you know to what extent should
one sort of read back onto that myth the
thing that then emerges and to what
extent was it something that uh was
there for for a different reason I I
tend to think that very often people
have a general feeling about how things
work
and that feeling gets expressed in
different ways as as myths as cultural
Traditions whatever else and it's only
uh sort of vastly later that the kind of
the science comes in to explain that I
suppose there have been a bunch of
things about uh the way we should live
our lives and yeah I mean there are
there are all kinds of things about uh
things that are virtuous things that are
not
things that we should do things we
should not
and much later kind of one realizes that
well actually there was a science reason
why that was a good or bad idea
um even though in a sense perhaps we
knew it was a good idea and we made up
stories to explain why it was a good
idea but we knew it was a good idea
because of something that got built in
sort of genetically on the basis of
biological evolution we knew it was a
bad idea to do this or that thing and
and then we sort of rationalized that
and turned it into stories that became
myths and then much later we realized by
looking by sort of reverse engineering
what's going on in our biology we
realized well gosh that's a a thing that
has some reason to be for some
scientific uh as a result of some piece
of science
all right well I think we should uh wrap
up that so thanks very much for joining
me lots of well we didn't we didn't talk
about very many questions today but uh
they certainly stimulated quite long
descriptions for me so I I hope people
enjoyed that
and I certainly enjoyed kind of thinking
through again some of these so thinking
through uh some of these kinds of uh
answers so thanks very much and uh bye
for now